[Music]
[Music]
hey folks welcome to the Dark Horse
podcast livestream I believe this is our
22nd livestream that's right
I'm here with dr. Heather highing and
Wow is there a lot going on in the world
we are gonna rise we are going to have
to talk about this and do some some
analysis I thought that actually though
in light of how much there is it's going
on and the fast pace of change I thought
it might be wise just as a counterpoint
to open with something that is important
but maybe isn't so much of the moment so
I had an important question for you how
sure are we that eating dessert in a
dream doesn't count this this is your
important question for me I mean you'll
agree it's important it's not oh well
I'm pretty sure it is but you have a
sense do you think it counts or do you
think actually it's a freebie it's it's
a freebie I just don't even know how to
respond to you here okay this is a
freebie is I'm less sure but anyway take
that as it is were you eating cake in
your dreams last night you know it
happens every so often and I must say
it's never great but sometimes it's
better than you'd expect having what
like listen to Marie Antoinette like
okay I'll just go ahead and do it all
right you know it's always hard to tell
in dreams what what actually took place
because you forget it on waking up but
yeah well all right so that's it for not
so timely but important matters you
wanted to lead us into this landscape so
people who maybe aren't aware of where
we've landed can be brought up to speed
before we do any analysis yeah first off
we want to show the clip from Mike
Nina's excellent three-part documentary
on what happened at Evergreen that we
tried to show last time but which really
does indicate how much what we saw on a
college campus three four or five years
ago has spilled out into the streets
right now so Zach if you would show the
clip from
the hunted individual I have to say I
keep being invited to talk about free
speech on college campuses and every
time I'm invited I make the same point
which is this isn't about free speech
and this is only tangentially about
college campuses this is about a
breakdown in the basic logic of
civilization and it's spreading and
college campuses may be the first
dramatic battle but of course this is
going to find its way into the courts
it's already found its way into the tech
sector it's going to find its way to the
highest levels of governance if we're
not careful and it actually does
jeopardize the ability of civilization
to continue to function alright so in
light of that in light of those
predictions that you made a couple of
years ago what's happening today one of
the things that is happening today June
10 2020 is a movement accompanied by
many hashtags to hashtag shutdown stem
hashtag shutdown academia stem being of
course the acronym for science
technology engineering and math and I
thought what we do first is show a
couple more clips from the very first
day of the public parts of the evergreen
protests and then show a little bit
about what the shutdown stem movement is
looking like today three years later in
on college campuses may I put a
placeholder before we go there that clip
is from Mike and you just a chat a clip
that we just showed is from Mike Maness
documentary and it was at Peter big
oceans table with Helen pluck Rose you
James Lindsay all present and mighty
Nina they're filming and my point is one
of the things that will come up today is
how much this was apparent in its early
phases to some of us and we were told
that it wasn't for real or wasn't
important but you mustn't get the sense
that this was invisible because their
whole reason we were sitting around that
table was that some of
were very concerned and yeah I think I
did nail it in that clip but so did they
and so so did many of us and you know we
were being told for years you know
really before Evergreen blew up we were
we were talking about this with people
we were being told that this was a few
niche faculty in the humanities and it
had no bearing on the outside world and
there was no way that this ideology
would have the the legs to get anywhere
and here we have people falling all over
themselves to be obsequious in the face
of a movement that is not what it seems
it just isn't you know with with regard
to the good faith protest that started
on the streets much of that is and it
stems from real real anger real hurt
over actual history of systemic
oppression the riots are not that and
the movement that has co-opted that and
may in fact have been part of what set
those protests in motion is not that and
certainly what is going on college
campuses is not that because the idea
that there is active and ongoing
systemic oppression of of everyone but
straight white males on college campuses
is flat-out batshit crazy it just is so
when we get to the analysis phase I want
to return to that clip and I want to
point a philosophy of science lens at it
because this is the day in which those
two things come crashing into each other
yeah they do alright so Zak do you want
to start with the so before actually let
me set this up on May 23rd 2017 the
protesters the activists the people who
would become rioters at Evergreen showed
up in your classroom Brett and and then
later in the day that was 9:30 or so in
the morning
later in the day there was another very
public meeting that almost became
violence on the fourth floor of the
library building the so-called four
o'clock meeting in between those though
was a private meeting between many of
the lead protesters I don't know how
many are there of them were there in the
room 10 or 12 and all of the top admin
at the Evergreen State College at the
time
the president all of the deans and I
believe all the vice presidents so in
which includes the Provost so all of the
top admin at Evergreen have met our
meeting with the lead protesters and
once again the activists have videoed it
and put it on put it online and someone
grabbed it and now and now we have that
video they put it online on Facebook and
an account that goes it's not involved I
think it's not my fault one it took
those videos and put them on YouTube
which is the only reason that we are
aware of their content that's right
that's right so we're going to show you
just a couple of tiny clips
the first one is President bridges
president of the college still president
to this day although soon not to be up
its own volition president of the
college promising re-education or
banishment of those who don't agree this
one is subtitled because Mike Nina
actually clipped this for me and gave it
to me in service of a talk that I gave
at Oxford last year on on some of these
very issues so you want to play this one
Zach they're gonna say some things that
we don't like and our job is to bring
what I hear us stating that we are
working toward is bring him in train
them and they don't get psyched
what and you must encourage I'm just
going to repeat they're gonna say
something said president bridges that we
don't like and our job is to bring them
on or get them out and when I hear us
stating that we are working towards is
bring them in train them and if they
don't get it sanction them and you must
and I encourage you to hold us
accountable to doing that very shortly
thereafter like 30 seconds later in this
over two hour long meeting for which we
have the entire video we have the lead
protester maybe the protestor who is
most instrumental in making the this
happen at Evergreen and you know by far
if not the least honest actor among them
one of them asking the administration of
the college well I'll let him speak for
himself if you want to play the sciences
as far as like education I thought like
these two issues because it's like I
know like one black woman on this campus
is often like wonder one or the only
like black and like black women person
in their classroom and basically just
has to sit there on the corner and
suffer through everything and like I can
buy up all my classes but then like
she's talking about because it's
[ __ ] it's deadly not just this was
like a 50 necklaces okay so Jamel starts
by saying is there any way to word some
sort of language about the commitment
towards really targeting stem in a lot
of this when we first heard that we were
shocked and then soon thereafter when
the protesters became rioters and
started doing both physical damage on
campus and actual assault and battery to
students who disagreed with them the the
places on campus that were targeted with
a library and the science labs the
windows of the science labs are broken
the Museum of Natural History was was
vandalized and the library was
vandalized which is exactly in keeping
with the idea that in order to get rid
of white supremacy we need to shut down
science technology engineering and math
so let me just say a few words about the
thing that is happening right now
before we go into more analysis we have
want to ask you to show a screenshot
here in a minute Sacopee would just show
both of us please yeah so this can show
my screen this is gizmo toes some
of the goals of shut down stem quote
white supremacy is baked into science in
academia from racist language and
textbooks to a culture that excludes
black scientists from innovating and
advancing at the same pace as their
colleagues but rather than more
milquetoast statements and diversity
initiatives researchers want action
organizers are asking the scientific
community to participate in a work
stoppage on Wednesday June 10th to bring
attention to racism in the world of
research just asterisk the idea that the
culture of academia and science is
excluding black scientists from
innovating and advancing is a claim for
which I have seen exactly zero evidence
but it is a claim that is being tied to
the claim that police brutality can
target black men in particular
disproportionately for which we do have
some evidence right those claims because
they both seem to be about racism are
linked and you're not allowed to
disagree with one for fear that you are
understood to be disagreeing with the
other okay next one howl insect take off
the screen please just a ok my my
trackpad is not working this is from the
actual shutdown stem website which you
can show us now those of us who are not
black particularly those of us who are
white play a key role in perpetuating
systemic racism direct actions are
needed to stop this injustice unless you
engage directly with eliminating racism
you're perpetuating it this moment calls
for profound change shut down hashtag
shutdown academia and hashtag shutdown
stem is the time for white and non black
people of color this is a new acronym to
me NBD POC no on black people of color
to not only educate themselves but to
define a detailed plan of action to
carry forward and Wednesday June 10th
will mark that day ok so we can take
that down that's one more thing the the
we are beginning to see the movement
splinter into its constituent parts and
then Zach if you would just walk us
through the six pictures that I had you
I had sent to you beginning with the
nature picture this is these are all
screenshots of tweets from the last day
or two this is
nature magazine one of the two biggest
most important preeminent science
journals in the world saying that they
are going to be joining shut down stem
striking for black lives is the is the
one of the tag lines that people have
become convinced this is what it's about
next from science the editor in chief of
science says science and scientists must
say out loud they have benefited from
and failed to acknowledge white
supremacy next one of many societies
professional societies this happens to
be the Society for research and child
development it is saying shut down
academia and genuflecting before the new
gods for we have some academics with
their version of well what they actually
say is looking forward to shut down stem
and having conversations with my
students tomorrow about racism in
academia as folks who hold any power in
academia is our responsibility to
disrupt the system and take
responsibility for ongoing contributions
to systemic oppression I read this as
don't hurt me
please move along nothing to see here
five this craziness from an academic hot
tip to lead Jassim for pointing this out
to me I hope there are a lot of circles
in academia having a serious
conversation on how academic freedom
upholds white supremacy racism and
Prejudice yep and finally sex we have a
PhD student zachary six saying i can't
read that
i'm not sure what it says among other
things she says the science can wait
because obviously in the middle of a
global pandemic the science can wait
well they have taken two pains they have
learned from the accusation that there's
something untoward about mass protests
when we should be social distancing and
so they have taken pains to exclude work
on kovat nineteen from there didn't even
at first they've added that in maybe
yeah they got some immediate pushback
there's a bunch to say here but i really
think the most important thing we can do
and we have to make sure to do a good
job of it before we're done here today
is to give people a sense for what they
are actually seeing because almost all
of this is euphemistic and not
straightforward its Potemkin it's not to
be taken at face value and frankly there
there are two experiences for us that
are happening simultaneously on the one
hand we are having a large number of
people wake up to the fact that what
they saw happened to us at Evergreen is
part of something much larger as we
tried to warn them and so on the one
hand that's reassuring that at least we
are not in a tiny group of people who
see it many more people are seeing it
this week than last for example but
there is also this increasingly
frustrating sense that we lived through
this in order to make it possible to
avoid having this takeover civilization
in other words I feel like we paid a
high price at least in terms of our
security in the world we were tossed
into a completely unknown realm and we
are still there we're doing fine but we
had tenured jobs now we were here on the
internet trying to figure out what our
new job is so in some sense this was all
for naught we went through this we you
know we we had the police withdrawn from
a riot against us and we watched the
community patrols descend immediately
into violence we know what happens when
you when you shut down the police and I
must say as much as it was surprising to
see Jamil talking so openly and on
camera about his feeling that stem was
the problem I can't remember the first
instance but somewhere in the year prior
to evergreens meltdown I remember it may
have been in a faculty meeting I
remember saying something about that
what was unfolding was a challenge to
enlightenment values and that we
academics had an obligation to defend
them and I remember being stunned to
hear an attack on enlightenment values
come back right not just
the Enlightenment right but
enlightenment values and you know at
first I wish I understand to be rigor
and logic in combination with compassion
for the humanity of all people right you
know maybe that's a sort of strict dual
ATO that's it's a really broad
interpretation and a more narrow
interpretation is just maybe about logic
and rigor and and using science to
understand what we do in the world but
even so even so those are the values
that you're fighting back against it was
stunning to be I did I didn't think
anybody could marshal such a broken
argument in public and not have you know
a faculty assembled for a faculty
meeting erupt in people saying wait no
you don't have that right you haven't
understood what enlightenment values are
then because you couldn't possibly be
attacking them but it was just silence
right and all are scared that is the
thing people need to understand is that
at some level we've said in other
contexts that frequently you will
understand what people are doing better
if you turn down the sound because we
humans can't help but process language
and if you listen to what people say
they are doing then you will often be
misled if what they are doing is not the
same thing and so you have lots of
people who are saying that they are
looking forward to talking about bias in
the sciences okay there's nothing wrong
with talking about bias in the sciences
it exists and it has a long and dark
history agreed but certainly certainly
up through the end of the 19th century
it was a print it was actually primarily
not just white and male endeavor but
also sort of a landed white and male
endeavors it was it was for rich people
and those rich people tended to be men
and those rich people tended to be white
and you know that what has happened in
the 20th century in part is an opening
up across all of those demographic
categories and you know obviously I have
benefited from it being open to women
but I think more so the vatic everyone
effectively who's doing science today
has benefited from it no longer being
just
appropriate for the landed gentry right
this is this is now actually open to to
anyone under some there's a move away
from that now we've talked a little bit
about the problems in modern science
before but the fact that in theory you
can get yourself into college and get
through and become a scientist no matter
where you came from
is wholly different from anything that
was true of the Western scientific
tradition up until I don't know at least
the turn of the 19th or 20th century
yeah the door is wide open which doesn't
mean people are walking through it in
numbers that are proportional to their
numbers in the population and it is
certainly worth talking about why that
isn't the case and what might be done
about it I think it would be wonderful
if people did show up in numbers that
were proportional but nonetheless if
you're scratching your head if this is
the first time you've heard
enlightenment values challenged or I
mean please understand shut down stem is
a new kind of tactic I tried to get
somebody to tell me if this tactic had a
name and a lot of people came up with
things that were in the ballpark but
nobody has come up with a description
the thing about shut down stem and it
works the same way for defund the police
you said these terms are basically a
floating point variable shut down stem
could mean what people presumably at
science think they're doing when they
use their platform to broadcast this
stuff that we are shutting down for a
day symbolically to acknowledge that
there's been some bias right
but how imagine that you were sitting
somewhere and you thought how can we
demonstrate our power let's get the very
top echelon of science to broadcast
hashtag shut down stem right and then
you realize that those same people who
seek this kind of power are also
actually broadcasting the message that
science itself is the problem that I
mean you heard their language that white
supremacy is baked in baked in baked
into science think about how
preposterous a claim this is right
scientific method you observe a pattern
you hypothesize a possible X
nation you come up with some predictions
that would be true if the hypothesis was
correct and then you run a test right
but they're pretending that the
scientific method is something like you
observe a pattern you come up with some
explanation that blames black people and
then you broadcast it without checking
right
no haz has science been done badly a lot
for absolutely has some of that bad
science been done badly in service of
racist goals yes is that happening in
the last 20 years I don't see any
evidence of it and and and we've gone
looking eventually even 50 years even
right and that's not to say that this
isn't pretty recent history and that
there hasn't been a lot of frankly evil
done in the guise of in the uniform of
science but that doesn't make it science
but just just like hashtag black lives
matter is cloaking itself in something
that sounds honorable and amazing and is
not actually that inside the idea that
eugenics or social Darwinism is actually
a scientific a scientific study it's not
it's the it's the same misapprehension
but even if it was let's transport
ourselves back 50 or a hundred years
right the cure for bad science is good
science and it always has been
science is a bias correction mechanism
that's really the only thing it does you
don't need science to tell you things
that are obvious you need science to
tell you things that are
counterintuitive which means that
whatever your biases are science is the
tool for addressing them and I would say
further let's imagine so if you listen
to the leaders of the movement and you
listen to what their internal
conversation sounds like they say look
white supremacy is so baked in that you
have to level the institution and
replace it with something else and
sometimes they will say something
Afrocentric right now let's suppose for
a moment that there was some other
system that was interested in what's
true that's what science is about what's
true and it was self-correcting which is
the beauty of science the thing that
separates it from every other method
let's suppose that you
did have an alternative method all the
better if it comes from Africa lovely
okay so you've got some other method
that is both self-correcting and
interested in the truth what will happen
to it if you set it in motion it will
converge on enlightenment science that's
what it'll do so at this point in a
global economy it will and we know that
there have been other enlightenment s--
you know the Enlightenment that we
talked about and when we refer to it is
the European enlightenment but the Maya
as we have talked about before the Maya
had an Enlightenment many hundreds of
years before the Europeans did and
although we know very little about what
their inner workings of their thinking
was because almost their entire library
was destroyed in fact by the Spaniards
when they arrived
although the Maya themselves were
already a culture in decline at the
point that the Spaniards arrived what we
do know is that they had astronomers
they had scribes data concept of zero
they had mathematics they had vast
written literature they had they had
they'd had an Enlightenment advanced
agricultural chemistry so I don't even
want to put caveats on it though you
need two characteristics to guarantee
that all you have to add is time before
you rediscover science right it doesn't
matter what the nature of a truth
seeking self-correcting mechanism is it
will inevitably land there and what that
means is that the right thing to do if
you really want to empower black people
and believe me I do if you really want
to do that
the best thing you can do is you can arm
them with the tools of science rather
than setting us back hundreds of years
and waiting for some other method to
converge on discoveries we've already
got you can arm them you can democratize
these tools which is exactly what we
were doing at Evergreen it is exactly
why they had to come for us now this is
the part that I think people are gonna
be totally bewildered by why if this
movement is so interested in empowering
black people would it attack a tool that
was really their best weapon in order to
end whatever oppression remains and
here's the reason this movement isn't
what it looks like this movement is a
false version of something that doesn't
exist to be found in large numbers in
other words the energy has been captured
by people
who are not well-intentioned and the
reason that they hate science is because
science is a good mechanism for figuring
out what's true and what they are
peddling is not true so the last thing
they want is people empowered to check
their claims because their claims don't
stand up and we saw this all over the
Evergreen debacle right when we said
okay you're telling us that there is
racism at Evergreen where's the evidence
and what did they say they said to ask
for evidence of racism is racism with a
capital R now that's obviously a
preposterous circular bit of logic but
the idea the more precisely to ask for
evidence of racism is evidence of racism
yep so it's inescapable it's
hermetically sealed by design so now
think about what you've seen you've seen
tens of thousands of people in the
street marching behind banners that seem
superficially like they might be pointed
in the direction of something good but
are actually Trojan horses hiding
something else most of them don't know
they're carrying Turgeon horses I don't
think they have no idea yeah and even
the ones so you point to some of the
tweets that people are you said that
they are basically saying don't hurt me
that's certainly a component of it but
there is something far more insidious
here when these people they see the mob
coming they look at their skin they say
oh oh I don't want to be backed against
the wall and they figure out what you
have to say in order not to get backed
against the wall to get the mob to move
on to somebody else a they are
externalizing harm on to the next person
right they have an obligation to stand
up and by not standing up they make the
mob stronger and then the next person it
backs against the wall has an even
bigger problem right so this is not cool
but the worst part of it and we've seen
it hundreds of times is the individual
says this thing to get the mob to leave
them alone
and then they've got a problem how the
hell are you gonna sleep after you've
done that right so what do they do they
tell themselves that it's true right
they forget what they knew and they tell
themselves this is actually the right
thing that's why I did it
and so now the point is the mob didn't
just
move on it actually captured their minds
right now the reason that people like us
were so animated
after the Evergreen meltdown was that we
saw this force take over lots and lots
of people who should know better and
after it took them over there was no
place there was no place that you could
say it stops here which is why I said in
that clip what I said it's why I said
the same thing to Congress all right
this is going to eventually spill over
into anything now truth be told I'm
impressed at the speed but nonetheless
the mechanism was obvious and well
anyway it's it is very important that
you think what is the most parsimonious
explanation for what I'm seeing is this
an honest confusion about whether
science is a good thing or is this a
demonstration of power yeah it is it's a
demonstration of power
let me show another screen Zak my
computer this is the particles for
justice site which is the site that
actually began I believe the hashtag to
God I've even forgotten what they're
calling it now shut down stem so strike
for black lives with the now-familiar
black power fist but this strikes me as
particularly important so this is put
together by some particle physicists
including one who will say a few more
words about here shortly this oops this
paragraph here therefore as physicists
we believe an academic strike is
urgently needed to hit pause to give
black academics a break and to give
others an opportunity to reflect on
their own complicity in anti black
racism and academia and their local and
global communities this is where it gets
interesting I think this hashtag strike
for black lives is in dialogue with a
call from colleagues in astronomy to
hash tag shut down stem and hash tag
shut academia for at least the day of
June 10th hmm there it is right so you
know there's there's Mountain Bailey all
over the place right and you you refer
to one explicitly in the last live
stream but for of those few people who
will stand up to this you can take it
down now Zack they will
be told look can't you stop what you're
doing for one day can't you can't kill
yet don't you care about black lives
that much and the most important thing
is what you were just saying that no
this isn't actually what it appears this
is not actually in service of ending
racism that is that is not what is going
on here although many of the people who
are participating think it's what's
going on here those two things can
simultaneously be true and they are but
just like defund the police oh we don't
mean defund we just mean like don't put
new funds - oh we don't mean abolish
we'd like but actually they do or at
least some of them do same thing with
it's a one-day strike come on can't you
get behind that what are you racist
well let's shut down stem and shut down
academia for at least the day of June
10th so let me say just a couple more
things what one of the instigators of
this particular madness is an
astrophysicist or a particle physicist
who wrote this piece Zachary
Shonda prescott weinstein or weinstein
no relation in response to the James
Dunmore memo the Google memo that was
that came out in August 2017 and we can
do a whole other live stream about that
we won't do that here in which the
headline that that slate gave her was
stop 'ok waiting science with truth and
it's exactly the piece that you would
expect given that to which I responded
let's see Zak take down my screen for a
moment wife well I find it I responded
here you go NSA and qualit should we
stop 'ok waiting science with truth no
so you know it's a short essay no
actually not it was it was more than
that but let me just share a couple of
things that I said there just a couple
of lines quote shutting down dissent is
a classic authoritarian move and will
not result in less oppression you will
send the dissenters underground and they
will seek truth without you science and
scientists need to respond the truth is
not in and of itself oppressive to the
extent that selection has produced
differences between groups such as
differences in interests between men and
women
denying the reality of that truth is
hardly legit
response so that is in reference of
course the d'amore memo which no did not
claim that men and women are differently
abled even he just claimed he could take
it down sack he just he just made the
observation which is backed by empirical
science that given free choice men and
women tend to make somewhat different
choices about what they're interested in
and what they want to do on average
between populations anyway so I want to
try to orient people to our perspective
obviously you hit the nail on the head
in your article that would have been in
2017 yeah so ok that's interesting you
and I have both predicted the future and
it has arrived quickly and in very
dramatic form but what I want to point
out is the philosophy of science is
actually applicable to this not
explicitly scientific discussion science
has you hypothesize the explanation for
a pattern and then make a prediction and
test it the purpose of that exercise is
not the testing of prediction scientific
experiment is not the sin qua non of
science the important thing is that the
hypothesis the model of reality that
generates the prediction gets credit for
the prediction when it turns out to be
true or in technical language
it remains unfalsifiable
so what that means is that when you've
got a true prediction you should look at
the model that generated it and say that
model appears to be somewhere in the
ballpark of correct what else does it
say that's the important part what else
does it say so just just make sure you
have to be very careful that your
predictions not just inherently followed
from the model but that there weren't
other models that made the same
prediction right you have to be careful
in both directions so there are lots of
things that tell you the quality of a
prediction so one of the things that
tells you the quality of a prediction is
if it's unique to the hypothesis in
question or does it reflect well on
several hypotheses at once another one
would be is it counterintuitive if a
prediction is intuitive then it's not a
very strong test if R objection is wild
to counter into
then it's a great test when it shows up
so for example Einstein's prediction
that the light of stars would be where
that light is bent by gravity which is
then tested by the observation that the
the Sun bends the light of distant stars
which is something you can't observe
directly and so we don't know it to be
true you can only see it during an
eclipse when the Sun is darkened but the
Starlight behind it is still visible so
you can detect this gravitational
lensing all right
that's an amazing prediction because a
it's so strange to imagine that gravity
is going to bend light nobody would
think to predict it it's really
counterintuitive and the second thing is
that it's it's so it's very easily
demonstrated so you're easy to check so
so the more people are surprised by a
prediction and who think it's not true
the riskier the prediction as it were
right actually if it is borne out the
better a test it is actually been of the
hypothesis in question rescue that when
when you have two predictions of
hypothesis both of which inevitably
follow from that hypothesis and they do
not follow from any other hypotheses if
you have a risky prediction at a non
risky prediction you can test the non
risky prediction but it is not nearly as
strong a test of the hypothesis than
testing the risky prediction yeah it
reflects weakly positively on the
hypothesis where as a deeply
counterintuitive totally unique
prediction reflects strongly on it but
here's the point now we have a thing
that's not an explicitly scientific kind
of prediction right you predict the
future I predicted the future Eric has
predicted the future so many times right
that the point is the real question is
okay how are you doing that right you
have a time machine or do you have a
model that tells you what's really going
on so that where other people are caught
off guard you actually see it ahead of
time and if so what else does your model
say that's the real question and so I
hate to be the one saying that because I
am among the people who have predicted
this event would happen but nonetheless
the important question then is all right
who got this one right shouldn't we be
elevating them in the conversation it's
not just us it's also Glenn Lowry it's
John mcwhirter it's
it's it's the it's those guys you
already mentioned the grievance study is
Peter Boghossian James Lindsay Helen oh
[ __ ] Rose lots of academics actually you
know ink just you know and across across
a number of domains who have
increasingly been saying wait a minute
hold up in Jordan Peterson obviously
maybe male probably most powerfully yep
for effectively saying what would it
have been 2016 2015 basically standing
up against compelled speech he wasn't
standing up against trans people he
actually I know this to be true as you
do has nothing against trans people real
trans people who are real but very very
very very very rare he was standing up
against compelled speech the idea that
if you do not speak the way that we now
speak that we have now agreed to speak
you are DISA you were breaking the law
no no we don't agree to that we do not
and he correctly predicted that Bill c16
would result in people having their
Liberty threatened if they did not use
particular language and this has now
happened either has been instructed on
what he is to call his own child in the
confines of his own home right
so Jordan Peterson was right that means
hey Jordan Peterson now has credit in
the bank with respect to his model
whatever it may be right who doesn't
have credit well as reclined blue it
Ezra Klein was busy rationalizing that a
lot of the things we hear people saying
they don't really mean and what we are
to imagine that they mean something much
more benign and they're just venting
well that doesn't turn out to be the
case these things it probably is true
for some of them again right but that
but no the fact that it is true for some
of them does not mean that the movement
isn't incredibly powerful even if it
starts as all movements will is a tiny
niche thing over in some made up fields
in the you know made up fields I want to
say you know they claim to be instead of
humanities and Social Sciences
but they just they don't they don't
deserve that title the humanities are
real and necessary to a full and rich
understanding of the human experience
the study of literature this too
history the study of philosophy these
are real and necessary fields when done
right and there are many ways to do them
right but almost everything that ends in
studies is not that so let's talk for a
second about Rhonda Prescott one I'm
gonna assume it's Weinstein just put her
over with Harvey done with it I won't
say that but I will say I don't want any
association with her nonsense but yeah
the the fact is we are not going to end
up disbanding science but they're shut
down stem thing is so again a
motte-and-bailey would have two versions
right you would have a strong version
and then a retreat position that was
secure right so the strong version is
there's some massive problem with
science and we need to transform it into
something new and then the weak version
is can't you just shut down for a day to
acknowledge that it hasn't all been
hunky-dory race wise in science in the
past right that retreat position is not
long but but the point is it wouldn't be
wrong if this was actually what it was
climbing to right but the idea what
would it cost if you were trying to
corrupt science magazine right now
science magazine is already corrupt but
if you were trying to corrupt it to your
own ends and you wanted to get it to
broadcast a hashtag of your choosing
right that reflected some bias of yours
the price point would be astronomically
high right science would be very good at
resisting anything that you tried to
bring into their office and disguise as
something lovely just to get them to
broadcast it to enrich you okay this
movement has actually managed to get
science magazine to broadcast shut down
stem right like if you asked me what
would you have to do to get science
magazine to broadcast a call to shut
down stem III would say it's impossible
but for the fact that at this moment you
have
I hate to say it I know they're
renegades among the Millennials we've
taught them for years but almost all of
our students for Millennials and almost
all of them were actually amazing and
interested in truth and interested in
discomfort if it allowed them a better
model of the world so yeah they wouldn't
easy it's easy to paint a brush across
an entire generation it is mostly the
Millennials who are protesting on the
streets and rioting on the streets but
we know we know that there are you know
a tremendous number of people who are
you know born into that generation who
are capable of simultaneously valuing
right rationality and compassion well on
the one hand the streets are everything
and on the other hand they're nothing
yeah okay
what's going on on the streets is part
of a larger plan all right so somebody
one of the people who I'm in dialogue
with on Twitter responded to my question
about is there a name for this floating
point variable term that allows you to
you know move a slider around with
respect what do you mean by shutdown is
that one day or is that permanently and
completely right so you're looking for
something that basically bought and
bailey is a binary yeah and you're
looking for the continuous I think you
his version of continuous variable we're
at the mob of a thousand people each
person can set the slider where they're
comfortable with it and they can all
move together towards this goal and then
you know the amazing aggressive position
wins in the end because all of these
people have advocated it thinking
they're advocating for their right level
anyway one of the people that I'm in
dialogue with suggested something I'd
never heard of before called above and
below which there's not much evidence of
this discussion I know that there's a
little it's apparently affiliated with
communism although I won't be surprised
if it's more general than this but it
has to do affiliated with the people who
are identifies communists or vehicles
were fighting communism know know
identify with communism and you know it
has to do with basically using creating
a mob to create the impression of demand
for some kind of change and then using
that impression of a mob that is
demanding change to get elected
officials and things to capitulate to
the public right it's sort of like a
pseudo populist thing I mean the public
if you told
public I don't know actually we're
really interested in shutting down
science you know they look at you like
you were crazy yeah I mean it is crazy
yeah
some some account with zero followers
which could be a sock puppet or it could
be somebody who's afraid and so has made
a new account tweeted something like how
ironic to broadcast hashtag shutdown
stem from your super sophisticated cell
phone yeah right I mean it is pretty
ironic but in any case we've got we've
got a power grab that has a game
theoretic mechanism for using whatever
power it has to marshal more and more
force the important thing is not the
street the street is like a
demonstration of the amount of energy
and the amount of energy is used to take
institutions and topple them from within
so I think the real story which we are
not seeing while we are paying attention
to the street is inside of every single
institution of a certain size there is a
mirror of what's going on in the street
taking place the New York Times we know
it's happening at the New York Times
Barry Weiss's talked about it well but
only we've also now seen you know
they've that yes the firings have begun
the fire and I don't I don't have it I
won't be able to pull it up so I'm going
to I'm going to paraphrase but there is
a something from the new editor in to
boy I didn't pull this up I don't know
what's the editor in chief who's been
replaced as well as the new editor of
the editorial section or just the
editorial section one of the new editors
has basically said to his entire staff
if you see anything anything at all that
strikes you is not quite fitting with
what we're trying to do here the New
York Times you let me know it's if you
see something say something if you see
something say something and it is you
know it is again simultaneously like
please I'm on the right side please
don't hurt me but it's it's encouraging
it's encouraging people to start
reporting out on their neighbors
and and their family members are you and
just it we know where this goes from
here we know where this goes but imagine
that you could peer into these
institutions imagine that you were at
science magazine now we don't know
anything about what happened in science
magazine other then something happened
that caused science magazine to
broadcast shut down stem and to stop
doing anything else for the day right
we know that the movement when you talk
to it directly is very clear on the fact
that it's not that they want to reform
stem they actually find stem to be their
enemy and we can infer why that is so
imagine the Millennials right we're Gen
X Gen X is a tiny generation it is now
sort of upper echelon in these
institutions right just by virtue of
seniority but other boomers are still
more senior but they're more senior but
they're also pretty old right and so
anyway there's a lot of there's a lot of
Gen X at the top but it's not very large
in numbers yeah actually I actually
don't think that Gen X is yet heading up
admins I think it's still boomers who
are heading up universities and colleges
and mainstream media and such well I
would say at the very top anyway
it's it's an interesting question and
it's you know it's an empirical question
yeah but in any case what you do have is
the rank and file in these institutions
is millennial there are a lot of them
they are rightly angry they've been
handed a bad deal terrible deal a
terrible deal so there's a lot of
interest in change not much
sophistication I would say about what
change ought to look like so it's really
just pent-up energy
well they had crap education at some
level they didn't this you know just
just returned to the that final point
that I made in those fourteen points and
I made a couple of livestreams ago
they've just as you said they've been
handed a terrible deal most of them are
dead they had terrible education they
have no chance of owning property they
have terrible health care they've mostly
been you know on legal pharmaceuticals
for so much their lives they don't know
even know how ordered their own moods
and their own psychologies or interpret
those of others and they're living
online and you know of course they're
confused and of course they're angry
well of course they're angry they're
good reason to being there
angry and a movement outdoors that is
formerly about the murder of a black man
but is actually quite obviously about a
demand for change has been co-opted by
people who are selling a particular
phony story about what's wrong and what
to do about it
but anyway there's a lot of fervor for
just signing on because hey change is
good if things suck change is good no
that's not true change I mean you know
the problem a lot of if you're now
listening to us because we correctly
predicted what was going to happen then
our current conversation is well we told
you this looked Maoist now project that
thing to the scale of Nations and you
know why this is preoccupying us but
inside of science right some battle
presumably took place or a bunch of
people who have behind them as they
approach the question of whether or not
to shut down one of the premier science
journals for the day and turn it into a
megaphone for the George Florida
protests all right they have images on
every screen of violent unrest in cities
across the nation and increasingly
across the world right so that seems
like a reason to listen and for the kind
of cowards who end up in administrative
positions in large institutions and
frankly it's a lot of cowards right
tirely we've known a few non cowardly
administrators but and they're gonna be
first against the wall well evergreen
one of them was yep before us he was
gotten rid of first Michael Zimmerman
indeed Michael Zimmerman who was very
courageous very courageous Provost was
shoved out by George bridges before the
madness unfolded I mean he he would have
been in opposition to it all the way
along so they got rid of him for the
same reason they got rid of us so anyway
the courageous people are gonna get
tossed out that's just what happens and
then the institutions are gonna topple
into the hands of this thing right
where does Shonda prescott weinstein end
up after physics has been brought to its
knees i think she's one of our new top
physicists
why because there aren't enough black
physicists which is probably true
well you know and you say this we say
this I at least have no idea what the
value what the rigor of her science is I
have no idea but she is clearly one
effect of this will be to to win in a
system that is supposed to be about
merit but in which she will win based on
her lineage the color of her skin this
is the kind of science that we had in
the 19th century yep it's a different
lineage that's winning now but it is
exactly what was going on then and it is
not legitimate it is not ok so at some
level I worry about just repeating it so
much that it gets lost but I've been
saying from the beginning that part of
the problem here is that there are two
movements fused together there are
people who earnestly want change in a
realm where it is necessary who would
love to end oppression and then there is
a cynical self-interested movement that
wants to turn the tables of oppression
and it doesn't turn the tables of
oppression on people who are actually
oppressing it takes these very crude
demographic measures of whether or not
you benefited from or paid the price of
some kind of historical oppression and
then it just simply rank orders our new
role in the world and it's preposterous
it's incoherent it's dangerous it
functions like a cult but the power I
think the problem is the power of this
perspective is in no way correlated with
the accuracy of the portrayal so you
have something that is a fairy tale that
is marching forward on the basis as if
it was the literal truth and it is going
to line us up against the wall it is
going to topple the institutions
suddenly it is going to be
understandable that you know the people
at science magazine the people at nature
the people of the triple a yes all of
the people who have broadcast shut down
stem are going to discover what that
actually means too late to do anything
about it so
this seems a decent moment to introduce
just a few short quotes from Orwell's
book 1984
I don't think actually we've talked
about this elsewhere that we are mostly
living in a 1984 moment this looks more
Huxley and it looks more like brave new
world
but both Orwell and Huxley had their
finger on the pulse of what what
authoritarian and totalitarian movements
look like I just think that brave new
world is a little bit more accurate in
its predictions of what the world is
that we're actually moving towards but
here's from 1984 which was published
first in 1949 quote for after all how do
we know that two and two make four or
that the force of gravity works or the
past is unchangeable if both the past
and the external world exist only in the
mind and if the mind itself is
controllable what then
so that's predicting post-modernism
mmm-hmm next quotient from Orwell every
record has been destroyed or falsified
every book has been rewritten every
statue and Street and building has been
renamed every date has altered in the
process and that process is continuing
day by day and minute by minute
history has stopped and finally another
quote from 1984 the party seeks power
entirely for its own sake we are not
interested in the good of others we're
interested solely in power pure power
what pure power means you will
understand presently we are different
from the oligarchies of the past and
that we know what we are doing all the
others even those who resembled
ourselves were cowards and hypocrites
the German Nazis and the Russian
communists came very close to us in
their methods but they never had the
courage to recognize their own motives
they pretended perhaps they even
believed that they had seized power
unwillingly and for a limited time and
that just around the corner there lay a
paradise where human beings would be
free and equal we are not like that
we know that no one ever sees his power
with the intention of relinquishing it
power is not a means it is an end one
does not establish a dictatorship in
order to safeguard a revolution one
makes the revolution in order to
establish the dictatorship the object of
persecution is persecution the object of
torture is torture
the object of power is
power now you begin to understand me
Carell in 1949
that's 71 years ago 71 years ago yeah
and he really needed a and Ezra Klein to
explain why he was overreacting I guess
yeah yeah it's it's amazing and you know
you're right I hadn't thought about it
till now but Orwell does predict
post-modernism that's what Newspeak is
right it's a completely nonsensical
language that inverts reality and I mean
so this is maybe not nearly as
interesting in light of what Orwell said
but there is an insane piece that came
out today
yesterday in the independent which is
has its headline changed but the
original headline was so this is about
the the kerfuffle in which JK Rowling
comes out with the insane stance that
sex is real and that men and women are
different and of course all of her so
many people are falling all over
themselves again to say don't hurt me
don't hurt me of course I deny
biological reality so can I just point
out if you don't think sex is real
you're doing it wrong I think you've
used that before damn that's
embarrassing yeah all right maybe maybe
not here maybe not you've just called me
out though great sorry my family has
gone full woke there now outing what
I've said at the dinner table
that's woke Wow okay so you know there's
there's again we will talk at some point
about the amazing and heroic JK Rowling
and what is going on with regard to the
responses to her but one of them is this
headline from the independent the orig
the original headline before it got
changed what the white supremacist roots
of biological sex reveal about today's
transphobic feminism you know what can
you do okay yeah it's just they're just
putting their you know there's their
crazy assed ideas next to the new
movement that no one who hasn't been
through this really seems to be able to
turn away from
and you know we're saying you need to be
not a racist and you need to be
anti-racist and you also need to reject
this yeah you need to and rejecting it
means that you will probably be called a
racist and that has become in the 21st
century one of the scariest things to be
called and until you were called a
racist and until I was called a racist
and the reasons for us being called
racist are a matter of public record
I've published the letter that I wrote
which was which was this that you guys
are not seeking to and oppression you're
seeking to turn the tables of oppression
before before you go through that
particular looking-glass it seems like
it can't be survivable right that you
cannot possibly survive someone calling
you a racist but the fact is someone
seeing that word about you or Nazi or
trans Fobo you know whatever number of
these ridiculous epithets are being used
now it feels like it's unrecoverable and
like you you you won't ever be able to
recover from it but the fact is that if
it's just wrong assuming you're not as
the vast majority of people aren't
racist or not say or transfer or any of
this other ridiculousness
then you do survive and you emerge going
huh that didn't kill me being being
called that did not turn out to do the
damage that they thought it would do I
have never been less happy to disagree
with you than I am right now okay um I
disagree with the amount I think that
perspective is now out of date as of a
couple of weeks ago okay so you think it
was true when we were going through what
we went through but it's not true now
well I think there was a way in which it
was true I don't think it was safe but I
think there was a way to to jump but I
think what we are now seeing is
happening at a scale and with the
ferocity that we are now back in a
landscape where the hazard of saying
what's true is high and that's that's
putting people in a predicament where
they're gonna have to make a real choice
it's not simple
but there's no winning if you if you lie
alright if you if you do this like
please don't hurt me or I'm going to do
everything I can to signal how woke I am
it's not like they won't come for you
anyway right no there's nothing you can
do to appease the mob there's nothing
that you can do that's sufficient and
the bigger your profile the more true
that is I'm not I'm not arguing that
this is a difficult choice I mean in
fact I was in dialogue with Robbie
George yesterday and we were both
remarking on the fact that people see
standing up to the mob as courageous but
that actually there there are certain
ways that you could be wired that it's
just there isn't a choice alright and I
feel this way for me for sure it was
like people say ha I'm so glad you you
stood up and you didn't count out of the
mob and it was like whoa I can't I so
can't relate to what that would have
been like that it's you know it was
automatic but but what I would say is
look you are gonna be offered a choice
whether you're going to stand up or
whether you're going to become complicit
with and then part of this mob and the
problem is I can't say that you will end
up winning if you say the right thing
this is a frightening moment we are
watching something with revolutionary
potential and it's telling us what it
wants and it's a frightening redo of
some of the worst episodes in history
what I can say is if you do the right
thing you will definitely feel better
about it and although the number of
people who will interact with you we
will talk to you may shrink dramatically
and the vileness of things that are said
to you and about you may go up you will
join the ranks of the courageous and the
intelligent people who have both of
those characteristics are going to end
up separated from everybody else by the
willingness or the necessity to stand up
and say what's true in the face of this
nonsense so and they won't think like
you in every other way and that's
important and good but the number of
people whom we now know whom we can now
see
and who are now known to us in the wake
of what happened at Evergreen three
years ago who are both intelligent and
courageous and who hold no truck with
this nonsense is large yeah I'm
concerned a little but I've seen people
decry the idea of the right side of
history as if there's something
defective about that claim as if it's
cultish to even imagine that such a
thing exists I regard this as nonsense
there is a right side to history it is
not always obvious to those in engaged
in its unfolding which side the right
side is and so it's not to say that
every interaction between two groups has
a right side right you're not you're not
making that claim of course not but
there are times when they're just simply
the right side and we all know what some
of them are but the point is what would
you do you know it's very easy to look
at the Nazis and know what the right
side of history was one imagines they
remember the German citizenry right no
one behaved that way of course but the
point is to say look there was a right
side and it was right then and it's
right now and it will be right forever
and so the question is what how do you
restructure yourself so that when that
moment comes you'll be on the right side
that's a valid question even if you
can't say I'm in possession of the
knowledge of which one the right side is
when something important happens but you
do want to be on the right side of
history and in this case if you are
paying attention I believe it is clear
which the right side of history is and
the thing that is so heartbreaking is it
it is not obvious that's going to be the
winning side here that's the question we
can ask you join us on the right side of
history it's clear enough we cannot say
join us on the winning side of history
because frankly the people on the right
side of history at the moment are pretty
scared at what they're seeing so this is
a choice for individuals and I can say I
have no respect for the individual who
has a choice who has enough security to
stand up who doesn't do it that person
is complicit and they are externalizing
harm onto innocent other people if you
think you're helping black people by
shutting down stem you have not
understood what's going on science is
the key to avoiding bias it is the key
to escaping oppression it is the key to
discovering what it is about our system
that
is systematically biased and eliminating
it so you are doing black people no
favor by challenging that mechanism the
question is do you have the intelligence
to see where we are and do you have the
fortitude to stand up to this nonsense
and say no I won't be party to it and if
you do then welcome and all I can say is
we will do our best to fight to turn the
situation around
let's hope we win all right
the reason we have reached an hour there
is of course a ton more to say I know
you had a great deal more that you
wanted to say and I did too but there
are there lives in the future so what we
will do now is we will take a 15-minute
break we will return to the link that
will be in the description of this video
we will answer your super chat questions
and I guess that's it in the meantime
like subscribe comment and stay strong
you